well brian first doses of the cobit 19
vaccine were once again being
administered today in clark county
this comes after a major winter storm
caused significant delays in shipments
really across the country
joe moeller joining us now live at the
las vegas convention center with an
update for us joe
yeah both cashman center and the las
vegas convention center here were both
back in full swing today after that
delay in
shipments and according to the southern
nevada health district now roughly
10 percent of the population here in
southern nevada has received at least
one dose right now those 65 and older
are now eligible to get their shot
during today's weekly copen 19 vaccine
update clark county officials said they
received the delayed shipment yesterday
and are receiving this week's most
likely tomorrow so they are now playing
ketchup
first doses were put on hold and some
second doses were canceled due to that
delay
this week the health district launched a
new platform on the website to set up
appointments the feedback on that
is good so far when you get canceled and
rebooked
we weren't sure if we were supposed to
call them if we were supposed to go
online
but the actual process of booking online
was fairly easy i would say
the health district also says they're
looking at ways to expand availability
with the rtc bus
transportation route to vaccine
locations and possibly opening a third
mega site similar to the ones here at
the convention center and also at
cashman and i also did want to note
that a gentleman i did speak with today
said he was only here for about 15 or 20
minutes so it is a lot quicker
and we know there are people out there
who are concerned about meeting that
second date to get their second dose
uh the best way to do so if you need to
get that appointment is to call
reporting live here at the connection
center joe mullen 8 news